hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round four of the
2019 Greinke chess classic it's paka
veja versus Valentin Anand
it's really an exciting game a lot of
attacking going on a lot of defending
going on and we do have some nice
footage from the great chess classic
video team and I've cleared my ROM cache
before recording this video so I do hope
everything will be in order
let's check it out we do have a nice
footage of of Anand here so hopefully it
will not lag and it's not lagging I'm
very happy about this so that's the
solution to my problem I just cleared
clear that cache before before before
recording there you have it very nicely
done and also we have a nice nice
footage of paco there we have it
pondering on the position just you know
not getting too excited even though you
know if you if you look at his face here
and then consider about what this game
will be like it's nowhere near as as
exciting as the game is so his game is
definitely his face is not a valid you
know showing off of the game quality not
quality but yeah you know what I mean so
without further ado let's check it out
Paco has the white pieces and he opens
with E for their Anand replies with c6
we have the caro-kann Knight to c3 and
d5 now very very principled Knight to f3
Bishop to g4 by Anand going for this bin
right away h3 asking do you want to move
back with the bishop or do you wanna
trade Anand decides the trade this is
all very standard even though it gives
up the bishop pair very early and east
six so you've got rid of your light
square bishop so now you can close your
points on light squares this is a very
solid structure and your dark square
bishop can be used to maneuver in
between the light square pawns as you
know as you please
g3 we have Knight to f6 by Anand and now
a3 and here there are a couple of games
in the database Bishop to e7 was played
here pawn captures on e4 was played here
9b d7 was played here Knight captures on
e4 was played here but Bishop to c5 the
move Anand place is a new move in the
position which is quite rare for a
caro-kann to heaven
position on move seven so what do you do
here here okay you have to ask yourself
can I go see five it's grabbing more
space but after night the d7 it will be
somewhat difficult to defend this point
you can't go d4 because the bishop is
now controlling d4 and you'll just have
to go back with the Queen either H Queen
h5 to defend the pawn and after your
opponent the Queen back with g6 you're
gonna have to go to e2 and you haven't
really achieved all that much so after
Bishop to c5
Paco just plays d3 strengthening the e4
pawn and now Anand castles with Bishop
to G to the Paco also prepares the
castle Knight B to d7 and now we do have
castles and the b5 Anand grabs more
space on the Queen side and here Queen
to d1 going back with the Queen as you
do want to push f4 first you have to go
King h1 or King H to add to push f4 but
here on doesn't allow it for the moment
and keeps the king where he is so yeah
even if you push go King h1 I'm just
gonna grab the f2 pawn so first you have
to defend it we have Queen to e2 not
preparing King h1 to push f4 and I don't
take this opportunity to further expand
on the Queen side we have a 5 and now
King to h1 f4 is ready to be played but
Anand still doesn't allow it we have d4
pushing the knight back Knight back to
be one going to the starting square
although there is an interesting move
that doesn't require the knight to move
back e5 but here after all the captures
let's say captures captures and captures
now you have to react to this as the
rook is not to defend it you can't go
pawn captures here you would have to
capture it and now after Knight captures
on f6 black ends up being up a pawn and
while you can you can mess up the King's
pawn structure here it's very unlikely
that you will be able to use this for
your attack as both of the Kings are
Castle kingside you can you can do some
maneuvering with the Queen here but
unless you can get some nice roof lifts
in it's really not not happening so
after D for Parker just goes back with
Knight to be won and now a sort of a 5
by Anand doesn't allow a 5 by white with
Knights to D - still waiting with this
a four idea and once again I'm sorry for
this sometimes you will see arrows
before I even make them it's a it's a
new glitch in the interface and I'm
sometimes I remember to fix it because
if I don't when I prepare a game I have
to go over the game one more time to get
rid of all the arrows and sometimes I
forget so sorry about that
Bishop to b6 gaining further control of
the f4 square hoping to prevent it but
Paco just pushes it with f4 and here you
don't want to capture if captures
captures you're just you know in trouble
now what can really start the attack he
can go Ruby g1 get the better part of
the way maybe bring the Queen into the
game and not not good for black so here
after I for just Queen to c7 by Anand
gaining further control of the f4 point
of the f4 square and then now f5 here
Paco closes the position he wants to go
g5 g4 and g5 and now on and Queen and
Bishop aren't really doing all that much
they are pretty much shooting at that
point on e5 now Knights to be six by
Anand Knight now takes control of the C
4 square he wants to push C 5 C 4 and
well hopefully survive the attack on the
King side and transfer the game over to
the Queen side we have G 4 by Paco s
plant and Anand simply continues to play
on the Queen side C 5 and here the best
idea for white would most likely be g5
just starting the attack right away but
after Knight to d7 Queen to h5 just g6
would be would be fine Queen to h6 and
now just look at the c8 and here you
don't have any problems it is an
uncomfortable position for black but
black is holding this you don't have to
be afraid of anything like this just
Bishop f8 kicks the Queen back so
everything is everything is perfectly
fine so this is one option for Paco to
go for but he decides to go for a
different line Knight to f3 first and
now just c4 by Anand still continuing
the game like nothing is happening on
the Kings side Bishop to g5 now hoping
to capture here and only then push g5 on
and it doesn't allow it he was night f2
d7
now comes f6 here Paco offers upon the
anand but anand isn't interested in
opening up any files DF file and also
his g file so he just pushes the jeep on
g6 and now yes it could be a bit
dangerous if you if you can get
something like queen f2 Queen h4 Queen
h6 and Queen g7 in but that's a lot of
moves and Anand also has something to
say about it so here we have Bishop to
h6 now forcing the rook to move which
isn't all that all that impressive as
one thing garland wants to do is get rid
of this rook fort from f8 so rook F the
c8 and now he opens up the f8 square for
his Bishop and now comes Knight to g5
Queen to d2 was also a possibility here
but then after Knight captures and f6
you have to give up this pawn white
white can play Knight captures on d4
here because now you open up the attack
from the rook to the night so you
wouldn't be able to capture the f6 pawn
so this would perhaps be an improvement
on Paco's idea Paco wins Knight to g5
and now you really are in a very
dangerous position here if I don't play
something like c3 then white gets a lot
of time and his attack will be
successful let's say you go B capture
spunk or Queen captures even now you get
Queen to f2 and now Queen to h4 is a
huge problem for black because now after
Bishop to f8 you're you're you don't
have time Queen h4 and now there's the
threat of capturing here Queen h6 and
Queen g7 checkmate
but also if you just capture then the h7
point is a weak so you can't protect
against both of them let's say Queen c5
you want Queen to be able to capture
here just Bishop captures on f8 is
sufficient because now you're attacking
the Queen and also threatening at
capture on h7 so if captures just screen
captures with checkmate and if you don't
play something like this
still just white white will just capture
bring the Queen to h6 and deliver
checkmate so it's not possible to go for
this with black Anand has to be very
careful after Knight to g5 and he finds
it the best idea Bishop to f8 right away
and now white attack is happening too
slow here Bishop captures on f8 was
played and now just night yeah
and now the Knight is guarding the h7
pawn so the Queen coming to hh4 will not
be all that scary for the moment but the
Queen has to has to get there we have
Queenie one now with ideas of Queen h4
to h6 but just Knight B to d7 and here
we have a four you might also try Queen
to h4 right away but just look here and
now there's a double attack against d f6
pawn queen to h6 will be too slow as
you're just gonna pick up the pawn and
there is no attack here so after 9b d7
we have a four we have pawn captures
rook captures and now come see capture
sound III C capture sound III and now h6
Anand kicks back the night so there are
no more dangers of getting checkmated
here Knight back to f3 and now comes
knight c6 the knight is no longer
neither than f8 as there is no point on
h7 we have Queen to h4 I'm going after
the point now comes King to h7 defending
the pawn and now
g5 and here and of course pushes h5 you
don't want to allow any any captures on
h6 and again we get this very
interesting position where all the
volunteers is on the Queen side from the
beginning of this game
Anand has been playing on the Queen side
and Anand said that this game is about
the Queen side but Paco claims that this
game is about the Kings side and now if
Paco can get rid of this night go Bishop
f3 capture this pawn on h5 we could
indeed have a mating attack here but how
do you do this the problem is if you go
Knight d2 then Queen to c2 attacks the
rook and the night here and you're not
you're not in time if Bishop f3 just
Queen captures Bishop captures on h5 and
now just to rotate rate is perfectly
fine to prevent any attack incoming
better g4 check you could go
Kingston g8 and now the Queen just has
to go back you can go Queen captures on
g5 you're down a piece you don't have
the attack everything is fine for white
for black
so after this h5 move you first have to
go back even though you don't want to
waste time this is one of those examples
where you have to waste time to save
time so rook 8 a 1 and now Queen to c2
of course you
phone allowed the Knights to retreat for
the bishop to come to f3 and now rook to
f2 attacking the Queen and Anand
calculates precisely there is time to
grab the pawn and now again if you go
Knights d2 you're not in time just Queen
e3 and if we should have three Queen
captures in g5 there there's no attack
happening here so after Queen captures
on d3 with Bishop to f1 we maneuvering
the bishop while attacking the Queen so
that saving time Queen to b3 and now
comes Knight to d2 preparing better up
here and captures on h5 again the arrows
tricked me Queen to b4 now with ideas
that if needed the Queen can go back but
also just keeping around at night and
but Paco tries it anyway we have Bishop
to e2 and here Anand has to decide what
to do does he go for the knight is
Bishop captures on h5 a threat or or
does he have to go back with Queen to f8
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the correct idea for Anand
here I'll give you a couple of seconds
while I have a nice if of my water for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
calculator and for those of you who just
won injured show Queen captures on d2 is
the correct move because after Bishop
captures on h5 which happened in the
game
Anand played Queen captures on g5 and
now Paco played Bishop captures on g6
with a double check from the Queen and
the bishop so now the only movie skin
captures here if you go back then you
are getting checkmated of course that
Anand did not go for that undone played
team captures here and now comes Luke to
g2 so Paco finally traps on and Queen
but the problem is he lost too much
material while going about it so Queen
captures rook King captures queen and
now rook to h8
not allowing any tricky ideas the rook
is now activated Queen g3 check and now
King captures on f6 we have looked to f1
check and brings the earth sorry Paco
brings a rook into the attack but King
to e7 we have Queen to a3 check and now
Knight d2 c5 just blocking that check
look to see one attacking the pin piece
but now
think the d6 the king is an active
player in this well sort of end game and
be for pawn captures Queen captures and
now just rook to b8 not allowing any any
sneaky checks from Paco you have to go
back now with the Queen Queen to c4 and
here unjust late King to e7 and it was
in this position that Paco y ahora
signed the game he resigned although you
might think what if you resigned there's
still much to be said about this game I
mean the Queen and rook on one side two
nights two rooks on the other side both
Kings
you know just running up and down the
board but there really isn't
there is no move that white can make
that would actually be a useful move you
can see that this rook is coming here
this rook is coming here this night is
coming here alright and white has no
moves let's say you go something like
rook to see to prevent rugby - then look
the b3 is coming just taking care of the
H pawn there's nothing wife can do about
it you can just play a useless move then
you can just capture the pawn rook
captures here you can just play another
move Knight captures here this Knight
controls about all of the squares where
check can even be delivered so real
controls before you can't give any
checks and after let's say queen f1 you
can go Knight to g5 bring another piece
into the attack rookie to just rock the
g3 check now you have to block and now
Knight f3 simply picks up the Queen
after Queen the King has no squares
after captures captures you are down a a
rook in the night you're getting
checkmated very quickly so although it
seems like a very complicated position
it's really not and both of them know it
so in this position Parker just resigned
in the game and an excellent victory for
Viswanathan Anand who joins Magnus
Carlsen in the lead as you all enjoy
standings so much I've prepared the
standings nope not that I've prepared
the standings after round 4 so there is
there we have it cousin Anne on ensuring
first place with three points then with
two and a half
Peter Svidler Fabiana Caruana maxima
Sheila Grove and 11 are onion with two
points are cut in a ditch and with one
point
Paco Vallejo and guru Meier and with our
star Vincent Kaymer
still in last place with 0 points
the the you know the tournament is still
young they're all what can happen yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
Paco who most likely didn't I would like
to thank David Compton Scott Raley shuns
table ski mark grandma grandma and
Arunachal some for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully today with another game from
the Greinke chest classic but I don't
know when I will return from from Zagreb
as I am really looking forward to
catching the the the Avengers end game
today but yeah that's it thank you all
and I will see you soon have an
excellent rest of your day